So didn't know what to do for the video
today.
I wanted to do something.
Why this song?
That really what I'm.
What I've been thinking about,
I've been thinking a lot about recently
could've been stopped and this is me,
my future self talking to my presence.
So fancy in material things.
I think what I'm trying to convey in
this part.
Sorry.
Okay.
The system to track that.
I know this isn't contract.
Jake,
switch out the.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I am not.
I wasn't.
This is not Jay.
Could you.
Could you come over here for a second?
Well,
these are the right metrics.
Integrity and dignity,
I think.
Yeah,
because what I'm saying is I'm not going
to sell myself out and then I check.
No,
no.
Certainly not six times a week at the
most.
Five days.
General to street.
I'm a normal,
normal,
normal regularity.
I was wrong.
Again.
That's true.
Is it gonna?
Would you put this injury?
Good.
Sort of like a
jerking,
jerking with a flashlight in on the
stove.
ICHOM head jerk.
Jerk.
Jerk it in way.